[Music]
hi there when you're doing a reading
exam how you read the text is very
different to how you would read a
magazine or a book in this video we're
going to have a look at four ways to
help you get the best marks you can in a
reading exam let's have a look at how
you read the text first the first time
you read the text read it quickly from
start to finish to get a basic idea of
what the whole text is about then read
the questions when you've understood the
questions go back and read the text
carefully this time look for key
information like names places dates
numbers etc sometimes the words from the
questions or synonyms may be used in the
text look for synonyms or related words
to the question and circle the key
information this will then help you when
you read the questions again and start
to find the places in the text where the
answers are you may need to read some
parts of the text two or three times to
make sure you get the right answers now
let's have a look at difficult questions
in a reading exam you'll normally find
one or two tricky questions the
important thing to do here is not to
panic if you can't answer a question
straight away don't worry leave it and
go back to it at the end don't waste too
much time on difficult questions you
can't answer it's better to focus on the
questions you can answer and go back to
these difficult questions at the end
once you know the questions you need to
find the answers in the text they're
often well hidden but the questions are
normally in chronological order this
means the first question will refer to
the beginning of the text the second to
the next part and so forth
it's a good idea to underline or
highlight key words to help you focus
and find the answers
finally let's think about what you can
do if there are difficult words in the
text that you don't know sometimes you
may not even need to understand these
words to understand or answer the
question if you really don't know a word
and you do need it to answer the
question see if you can use the context
to help you guess the meaning read the
sentences before and after the sentence
you're focusing on to help you with the
context it will also help you if you can
see what type of word it is is it a noun
an adjective and adverb does the word
have a positive or negative meaning also
think about the topic of the text which
words do you know related to the topic
could it be a synonym or is the word
made of words you already know but for
example peanut butter from your
understanding of the words peanut and
butter you can assume that it's like
butter
but made of peanuts
[Music]
for more tips on learning English and
preparing for your English exams
subscribe to our Channel and visit the
learn English teens website where you
will find loads more learning material
[Music]